we do have a bunch of primary elections
today but last night on the eve of
several of the last primaries The
Associated Press called the Democratic
nomination for Hillary Clinton many
Bernie supporters saying this was a
tactic to suppress voter turnout today
we will talk about that the associated
press saying we'll listen if you look at
the pledged delegates that Hillary
Clinton has already earned and you
combine that with what we now estimate
to be the superdelegates support that
she has she has surpassed the required
2383 combined delegates in fact 2384 the
total number estimated by the associated
press the New York Times quickly jumped
on it also saying that hey the
Associated Press has declared Hillary
Clinton the presumptive nominee by
reaching out to super delegates who had
not announced which candidate they would
they would be supporting and confirming
that enough were backing Hillary Clinton
to get her to that magic number of 2383
so what do we think about this I mean on
the one hand super-delegates have not
voted so to call this clinching the
nomination would be wrong but that is
not the language that the Associated
Press used at least in their sort of
explanation article that they published
after on the other hand the the numbers
don't look good for Bernie Sanders
obviously but the question of timing has
been brought up and motive right before
multiple primaries which while very
unlikely to change the eventual outcome
of this race could could Louis make
people say oh I heard yesterday that
Hillary one so I'm not going to vote
today that is a legitimate concern
although whether it could really change
the eventual impact of this uh less
certain about that and in that way this
is really irresponsible uh I guess we
come to expect that from from corporate
media and and the like um but it's it's
pretty juicy stuff and I understand why
they did it well the key thing is that
nothing official happened right
yesterday enough people who don't vote
until July told The Associated
press that they would be supporting
Hillary Clinton in the AP published a
sort of explanation article afterwards
here's a quote from that article from
the AP explaining this Clinton is now
the presumptive nominee because
according to our count she has enough
delegates backing her candidacy to win
the nomination AP will not call her the
nominee or as Newt Gingrich like said
what used to say the nominee until she
reaches that milestone in phila
Philadelphia next month when the party's
delegates former formally cast their
vote at the convention the Sanders
campaign almost immediately putting out
a statement about this which I will also
show you saying it is unfortunate that
the media in a rush to judgment are
ignoring the Democratic National
Committee's clear statement that it is
wrong to count the votes of
super-delegates before they actually
vote at the convention this summer
Secretary Clinton does not have and will
not have the requisite number of pledged
delegates to secure the nomination she
will be dependent on super delegates who
do not vote until July 25 and who can
change their minds between now and then
they include more than 400 super
delegates who endorse Secretary Clinton
ten months before the first caucuses and
primaries and long before any other
candidate was in the race uh Hillary
Clinton campaign also commenting
tweeting they also are not ready to call
this saying we're flattered AP but we've
got primaries to win California Montana
New Mexico North Dakota New Jersey South
Dakota vote tomorrow it's interesting
that when even the declared winner is
saying it's too soon to declare
themselves a winner but I think this is
political posturing Louis she also
doesn't want to dissuade people from
voting yeah and uh this is the
appropriate response is that this this
what you have to say uh you are going to
accept the nomination bestowed upon you
by the associated press right uh so yeah
okay however the interesting element
that is now being added to this as we
get ready as people are already voting
across the u.s. today in a variety of
states a White House source has said to
CNN that President Obama is eager to get
going in
I'm painting for Hillary Clinton so we
may see an endorsement from President
Obama sooner than later and some Bernie
Sanders fans are angry about the
possibility of an endorsement from
President Obama before Bernie Sanders
even formally exits the race but I want
to remind you that in 2008 Bernie
Sanders endorsed president obama before
Hillary Clinton formally exited the race
coming two days after President Obama
sort of on paper secured what appeared
to be the the required number of
Delegates and super delegates so I think
that that criticism would be
hypocritical unless you were also
critical of Bernie Sanders back in 2008
course many sander support supporters
quite young in 2008 that is true uh I
don't think a president should uh a
former president fine I don't think a
president who's an office should endorse
a candidate will hold on a second ad at
any point or before they are the
official nominee I mean it no rational
point just stay out of it really I mean
Lewis its traditional that the the
audition I don't give a you know what
about tradition you just say the sitting
president should not be involved in at
all in the election that will determine
their replacement yes that's exactly
what I'm saying and on what bands I also
believe that uh there should be one term
served it can be longer if you'd like I
mean a president should a sitting
president should also not be running for
reelection you say one term and that's
it that's what I'm talking about we'll
look at what happens in Congress where
you're up for re-election every two
years essentially forty percent of your
time in office is spent campaigning our
believe me I know and not that the old
similar rule should be applied to
Congress interesting all right send me
your thoughts on this a term limits
we've discussed term limits before
number of interesting reasons uh that to
me are relatively compelling to impose
term limits at at different levels of
elected office